monsieur béchade bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur arte
france alors première question pourquoi
est ce que c'est capital finalement de
refaire une refonte de ce pacte dès
maintenant d'où vient cette volonté
ça vient de deux choses d'une part la
crise qui a quand même profondément
modifié la donne et cette volonté de
rebondir de ressortir de la crise par le
haut en effectuant de grand changement
alors certains appellent ça le grand 8 7
énergétique et ça va effectivement
correspondre à des investissements
communs d'une ampleur jamais vue
naturellement à la dernière fois que le
pacte de stabilité a été revu c'était en
2005 voilà donc on est aujourd'hui
placée devant ces impératifs budgétaires
avec des croissances qui ont été
fortement abîmée et on compense cela
évidemment avec des politiques
budgétaires extrêmement expansionniste
mère justement comment enfin
concrètement comment est ce que le pacte
de stabilité peut accélérer la
transition écologique
en donnant aux états les moyens
financiers de décarbonée c'est un effort
commun mais certains pays ont besoin de
beaucoup plus de moyens que d'autres si
par exemple vous prenez la france la
consommation ou la trace carbone d'un
citoyen français aujourd'hui elle est
très très inférieure à celle d'un
citoyen allemand du fait du mix
énergétique
sans nucléaire désormais en allemagne à
partir de 2022 et qui a entraîné la
remise en service le service de
centrales au charbon centrale caucase
le même problème d'ailleurs en
angleterre qui ne fait plus partie de
l'ue veut mais quand c'est un problème
global comme la pollution les particules
elle voyage et on peut pas dire qu'un
pays
peut se régénérer de participer à
l'ensemble des efforts pour réduire
les émissions carbone justement vous
parlez de cette différence entre les
pays quels sont les pays qui ont plus
besoin des aides en europe
alors pour l'instant ce sont les ex pays
de l'est je pense notamment à la
roumanie je pense à la pologne où
l'essentiel de la production
d'électricité est encore au charbon et
quand on parle de faire circuler des
voitures électriques des vélos des
trottinettes si vous mettez de
l'électricité produite au charbon si
j'ose dire votre thiney tvo vélo boulot
charlon voilà donc ces pays là vous
réfectoire besoin de pas mal de soutiens
alors on l'a vu il va falloir convaincre
bruxelles est-ce que vous pensez que
cette refonte allait finalement
réalisables d'un point de vue européen
et qu'elles sont quels seraient les
principaux l'obstacle principal à cette
refonte d'après vous
alors si effectivement un sujet
politique
pour l'instant vous avez huit pays
frugaux sur les 21 que compte
l'union européenne qui veulent qu'on
revienne aux strictes au respect strict
des règles qui ont été édictées au
départ de ce hack de staline et donc sa
pire ça ne remet à juin 1997 et modifié
en 2005 pour tenir compte éventuellement
de problèmes de croissance après un pays
plutôt qu'un autre
l'allemagne se situe du côté des frigos
quand on voit la trace carbone de
l'allemagne ont ce type e ils ont besoin
de faire des efforts et en plus de ça
leur croissance vient d'être révisé à la
baisse ils ont eux-mêmes raidisseurs
croissance à la baisse donc sans
croissance ou avec une croissance bien
moindre comment vont-ils pouvoir
financer une transition écologique donc
s'ils veulent se donner les moyens ils
vont être obligés de profiter aussi de
la
marge de manoeuvre on s'est ménagé à
carter 2005 pour faire face à des
événements
exogènes
extraordinaire philippe béchade merci
pour votre éclairage merci d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien merci à vous